les projections actuelles
nous rassurent qu'on va avoir assez de
ressources pour aider à travers le pays
mais on est toujours conscient que ça
pourrait changer donc on est en train de
préparer des plantes contingence on est
en train de parler avec d'autres pays
d'ailleurs pour assurer qu'on ait des
ressources dans les semaines et les mois
à venir si effectivement la saison se
prolonge tout au long de l'été il y a
une tendance quand même en moyenne à ce
qui est de plus en plus donc va falloir
se poser ces questions là ce qu'on a
besoin de plus d'avions système est-ce
qu'on a besoin de plus de personnes
est-ce qu'on a besoin de faire des
travaux pour protéger certaines
municipalités
alors le gouvernement fédéral a fait le
point ce matin sur les feux de forêt au
pays en présentant ses prévisions ça
laisse présager que la saison des fûts
forêts pour être particulièrement
sévères tout au long de l'été jusqu'au
mois d'août j'en parle avec Yann
boulanger chercheur en écologie
forestière à Ressources naturelles
Canada un expert en incendie de forêt
changement climatique avec une équipe
monsieur boulanger je pense vous avez
préparé à travers le pays c'est ces
modélisations là bonsoir bienvenue 24/60
écoutez on écoutait ça ce matin pour mon
Dieu trois mois
la carte du Canada est en rouge Québec
est en orange qu'est-ce qu'on doit
comprendre de ce modèle qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est-ce qui cache au fond ce
modèle oui mais enfin on utilise les
prévisions saisonnières notamment au
niveau de la température des
précipitations qui sont émises par
Environnement Canada parce que ce sont
deux variables évidemment qui sont très
importantes pour prédire jusqu'à quel
point les conditions météo vont être
propices au développement des incendies
et à leur propagation et donc en ça
c'est donner là qui sont évidemment pas
très Jojo je vous dirais pour pour la
suite de l'été parce que on s'attend à
ce qu'une bonne partie du Canada soit
dans les conditions qui vont être très
au-dessus de la normale concernant les
les indices forêt météo donc ceux qui
mesurent la danger les dangers de feu de
forêt c'est vrai pour le mois de juin le
mois de juillet le mois d'août il va pas
nécessairement pour le Québec mais il y
a quand même des conditions qui vont
rester au dessus de la normale pour
l'ensemble du pays il inca tenté
au-dessus sévérité prévue au-dessus de
la normale parce que tout mettons toute
la carte est rouge orangée mais on parle
est-ce que ça cible essentiellement les
zones forestières où ça cible aussi des
impacts pour les zones urbaines ou pas
qu'est-ce que comment on doit lire ces
tableaux oui mais c'est essentiellement
des des conditions météo en fait qui
sont propices au développement des
incendies ces incendies là évidemment se
produisent essentiellement
essentiellement en forêt ils peuvent se
propager évidemment on l'a vu
malheureusement dans ce qu'on appelle
l'interface périurbaine donc dans
l'interface qui est près de près des
villes mais donc effectivement on peut
s'attendre à ce que l'ensemble du Canada
observe des conditions qui vont être
très au-dessus de la normale pour la
propagation et pour le danger d'incendie
êtes-vous êtes-vous et avec vos
collègues étonnés ou inquiets d'avoir vu
l'explosion dans le fond de ces feux de
très tôt en saison pense à l'Alberta et
même on est encore au printemps oui
effectivement donc c'est une situation
qui est franchement exceptionnelle on
voit le taux d'accumulation de de
superficie brûlée au Canada qui est
sans précédent je vous dirais le depuis
au moins les 20 dernières années du
moins depuis les depuis qu'on compile
des années des données au niveau
satellite on voit que c'est très rapide
on est déjà rendu à 3,6 millions
d'hectares brûlés au Canada ce qui est
déjà bien au-dessus de la moyenne
annuelle qui est à 2,5 millions
d'hectares ce qui est particulier aussi
cette année c'est que ces feux là
surviennent pas seulement que dans une
seule région ou dans une seule province
il surviennent je dirais d'un océan à
l'autre donc on l'a vu des feux en
colomberie britannique en albertin
Saskatchewan au Québec évidemment en
Nouvelle-Écosse donc une situation qui
est quand même très très particulière en
même temps je pense le rapport rendu
public aujourd'hui nous apprend nous
confirme qu'il y a eu 100 000 Canadiens
déjà évacués on est en début de saison
c'est est-ce que est-ce que ça pourrait
changer est-ce que les prévisions
d'Environnement Canada pourraient être
fausse au fond on a pas Saver ne pas se
confirmer est-ce que vous avez est-ce
qu'un petit brin d'espoir que ça change
aussi
de prévisions à long terme il y a quand
même une incertitude qui est très
importante
mais dans le fond ce qu'on voit ce sont
les tendances à long terme on voit que
de façon générale les modèles nous
prédisent puis pas seulement je
regardais aussi d'autres modèles les
modèles américains nous produisent aussi
que l'été sera particulièrement chaud
dans plusieurs régions du Canada donc on
pourrait s'attendre évidemment c'est pas
parce que les conditions sont chaudes
sont sèches que nécessairement les feux
vont se produire permettra d'autres
éléments aussi ça prend bon évidemment
il y a déjà beaucoup de feux qui sont
qui sont allumés mais pour avoir des
nouveaux feux bien évidemment ça prend
des émissions soit de cause naturelle ou
de cause humaine mais on s'attend donc à
ce que les conditions soient vraiment
très défavorables à long terme et plus
ça court terme je pense que c'était
mentionné précédemment dans l'émission
mais on s'attend aussi entre autres au
Québec est-ce que les conditions demeur
sèche
sans trop de précipitation notamment
pour le nord-ouest du Québec et donc on
s'attend pas à ce qui est un répit dans
les prochains jours voir les deux
prochaines semaines dans notamment au
Québec alors si on parle de tendance
puis je referai au rapport de les
différents rapports du GIEC et où ont
mentionné que le Canada serait une zone
à haute intensité avez-vous l'impression
que c'est prévisions là du géant qu'on a
peut-être pas entendu ou écouté ça
commence à se confirmer de manière
dramatique
effectivement ça se confirme de façon
assez assez nette on sait que le Canada
se réchauffe beaucoup plus rapidement
que ensemble du globe à peu près deux
fois plus rapidement ce qui fait en
sorte que les conditions notamment
reliées les conditions météorologiques
sont importantes pour le développement
des feux sont beaucoup plus sévères
premièrement notamment au Québec que ces
conditions-là surviennent plus souvent
que la saison des feux aussi s'allonge à
savoir que les plus qu'elles survient
plutôt au printemps qu'il se termine
plus tard à l'automne on observe aussi
une augmentation dans le fond des des
superficie brûlées au Canada on sait que
ça a doublé depuis la fin des années 50
entre autres et on voit aussi que les
investissent pas les investissements
mais du moins les dépenses qui sont
faits pour contrôler pour maîtriser ces
feux là aussi augmente de façon
significative le cours des au cours des
dernières décennies et on prévoit
qu'avec l'augmentation des températures
et des conditions plus sèches dans les
prochaines décennies selon les
différents scénarios climatiques on
devrait augmenter de 2 à 4 fois les
aires les superficie brûlées par rapport
aux 30 dernières années donc les impacts
sont sont effectivement très très
importants avez-vous l'impression que
cet été donc on va vivre ces événements
extrêmes bon finalement convaincre
beaucoup de monde qu'il y en a des
changements climatiques puis qu'il faut
agir en terminant je le sais pas
je demande
oui je vous dirais que dans le fond
c'est un bel exemple dans le fond
évidemment on peut pas c'est toujours
difficile de l'attribuer au changement
climatique mais les probabilités
d'observer une une saison comme on l'a
vu présentement au Canada s'accentue et
sont accentués dans le temps en raison
des changements climatiques monsieur
boulanger c'était fort passionnant
inquiétant un petit peu mais fort
passionnant et nécessaire à entendre
merci beaucoup pour votre travail merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]